there was College like professors that
have openly said things that
discriminated against men when I was in
college
openly and like there's no pushback but
not everyone has the ability to
homeschool their children because you're
saying you're intelligent you can do
that but not everyone you don't really
need to be that intelligent but I could
probably educate my daughter to a
certain level but there's so much really
my brother's 15 years old he showed me
he's like GCSE maths test and I was like
what the hell and I have a degree yeah
there's ways to do it though you'd have
to get a true and come to the house or
whatever wait you've got more control
and saying import and raising your child